Speaker 1: Today we're going to
be speaking with Chris Finan,
who's the executive director of the
National Coalition Against Censorship
and also author of the book How Free Speech
Saved Democracy. Chris, really great having
you on. I appreciate it.
Speaker 5: Well,
thanks. I appreciate you having me.
Speaker 1: You know, we've had conversations
about the First Amendment that were very legally
oriented and we've had those often with law
professors and others. One of the interesting
things about your book is that you delve more into
the history of when the suppression of speech and
the fight for free speech were. You contextualize
it in history in some interesting ways, and one
of the things you point to just to start somewhere
and we could start anywhere. You talk about war as
being one of the big culprits used by governments
to suppress free speech. And I think that won't
come as a huge shock to many in our audience
when we understand the idea of for the purposes
of supporting the troops for national security,
whatever, don't say this or say that. That, I
think will make sense. But can you talk about some
of the examples of when war was used in this way?
Speaker 5: Sure. Because actually war. World War
One was a civil liberties meltdown in this
country and actually precipitated lawyers
for the first time to start thinking about using
the First Amendment to protect speech that the
government might not agree with. You know, the
the the Sedition Act and passed by Congress in at
the behest of President Wilson actually provided
prison sentences of up to ten years for people who
spoke out against the war. And it was ultimately
used to prosecute over 2000 Americans, some for
the most inane kinds of criticisms like Wilson
as a block or people who circulated petitions
you know the most today. What we would say is
the most frequent forms of speech were suppressed
and and people were sent to jail. Over a thousand
people were sent to jail. Many lives were ruined.
And it was against that background
that the ACLU was formed in 1920 and
and began to fight. And, of course, you know, in
subsequent wars, we would see similar efforts at
suppression, certainly during the Vietnam War.
Speaker 1: But what modern administration and
we can include the Vietnam War era in that
I mean, you know, in the last 80 or so years
was most harmful, I guess is the word I would
use when it comes to suppression of speech. Is
there is there a clear administration, I guess.
Speaker 5: Well, yeah, Wilson clearly stands
out because there was so there was so little
law actually on the First Amendment before
the 20th century. And there had been a whole
century before and go, you know, go all the
way back to the Alien and Sedition Acts right
at the turn of the 18th century into the 19th.
Newspaper editors were thrown into jail for
criticizing the administration of John Adams.
And so so there was but there was very
little law on First Amendment rights before,
you know, before World War One. So and then,
you know, the there were certainly efforts
during the the the Nixon administration around
the Pentagon Papers, efforts to suppress. Right.
You know, that very critical study of the Vietnam
War. You know, Daniel Ellsberg was actually
indicted for sharing that with The New York Times
and The Washington Post and and might well have
gone to jail if the Supreme Court hadn't stepped
in and said that that that was protected speech.
Speaker 1: Are you surprised or I guess what
do you make of how the American right wing
recently has very proactively claimed
free speech as one of its core tenets,
despite sort of not only having a shaky history on
the subject in the past, but even while claiming
that as one of its tenets, you know, talking about
Trump wants to jail flag burners or open up libel
laws, which basically is code for make it easier
to sue newspapers and media outlets for doing
journalism. Is it is it surprising historically
that you would see that seeming conflict? And
what else do you sort of think about that?
Speaker 5: Well, it's wildly ironic. Yeah, it's
wildly ironic to hear conservatives advocating
as defenders of free speech when over the course
of American history they have been the major
violators of, uh, of, of that freedom, because
they've often been in the majority. And the people
who have been advocating for free speech have been
people fighting for equal rights. And that was
something that, you know, they opposed. And,
you know, this goes back to that goes back to the
abolitionists and to the women, women's rights
activists and activists for sexual freedom. You
know, they you know, they have at every turn,
conservatives have tried to suppress suppress
their speech and right through the civil rights
movement, of course, and into the into the modern
era. And as you say, Donald Trump was a big
and, you know, waved the big stick against the
press, called the press the enemy of the people.
So, yes, to suddenly see conservatives
advocating, you know, for free speech rights is
ironic and also difficult for us because it
alienates our kind of our traditional base,
which is young people and
liberals and progressives who
have been part of those equal rights fights.
Speaker 1: There are many accusations hurled
at the left about suppressing speech, including
different types of alleged censorship on college
campuses, both when it comes to alleged lack of
political diversity among faculty, but also as it
pertains to invited speakers to college campuses,
has become a very big kind of flashpoint to some
degree along the lines of LGBT discussions. Most
recently, when it comes to trans rights, the right
will sometimes hurl allegations at the left. What
do you think is the biggest area of concern on
the left when it comes to stifling free speech?
Speaker 5: Well, I think you know, I think and
that, again, is, you know, a change in the
political climate around free speech. But,
you know, I think that it's understandable in a
world that's suffused now with misinformation and
hate speech, that that people progressives have
sometimes tried to suppress speech themselves. And
we are concerned about those efforts on campus.
And we are concerned about we certainly support
the right to protest speakers and on campus and
to and to present the other view. But we really
think it's it's a mistake to try to suppress
them, because then conservatives just turn
around and point to that as justification
for the suppression that they want it.
Speaker 1: Right. Yeah. My view
on this has been, you know,
an unsavory guest is invited to a campus,
someone I'm not interested in seeing. Fine.
If they have been properly invited and there's
no criminal issue and whatever else certainly in
there's nothing wrong with the invitation and the
fact that they have an event protesting outside
the event. Absolutely fine with it. The protesters
shouldn't be restricted to some pen a block and a
half away where nobody sees that you're absolutely
fine. Once the event starts, it does seem to me
that it's correct to allow the speaker to
speak, and then you can continue expressing
your displeasure during a Q&A, for example, the
counterpoint will be, Well, there might be no Q&A,
so your only opportunity is while the Speaker is
speaking, or may I understand that it starts to
get to one of these things of, well, you know,
the protests can't only be the way everybody's
comfortable. Part of protesting historically is
sometimes the protests happen in a way and at a
time and in a place where it is an imposition on
someone else. But fundamentally, I do think that
preventing the speaker from speaking is a mistake.
Speaker 5: Yeah. And I think it also applies
to trying to revoke invitations that have been
made to speakers. If there are people on campus
who want to hear that speaker, they should
have the right to hear them. But by the same
token, that those who don't have an absolute right
to protest and but we don't want to you know, we
don't want to say free speech only for our side,
which is really what the conservatives are saying.
It's it is free speech for us and not for you,
because then that lays the groundwork for what
we are seeing now around the country, which is
this hundreds and hundreds of challenges to books
in schools and libraries that progressives care
deeply about. These are books about race and the
persistence of racism in America and how to look
at slavery in and around the lives of LGBT people
and, you know, their right to be represented
in school libraries. And and so, you know,
we can't we have to protect this is the classic
statement. We have to protect the rights of all
in order to ensure that everybody has rights.
Speaker 1: When it comes to the book, banning,
you know, the truth, as I have researched it,
is that the right is overwhelmingly the side
that has the lists of books that should
not be in libraries. But very often the
right will hurl back at the left, look at what
happened with Dr. Seuss. They cancel Dr. Seuss,
etc. To me, it does not seem analogous for
a publisher to decide we're not going to
continue new editions of certain books because
some of the imagery or messaging is outdated
based on current norms. That's very different
than Here's a list of 20 books that shouldn't
even be available in the library. From your
perspective, are these two very different things
or are they equivalent the way the rights states?
Speaker 5: No, I don't think they're equivalent.
I think that in their in the cases are very
slim know the cases that they can point to
of alleged suppression of books certainly just
don't hold up to the overwhelming majority of
challenges to books in schools are coming from
coming from conservatives and parents who just
don't want their kids or anybody else's kids
to have access to books that in many cases are
lifesaving because they they show LGBT kids
that they belong, that they are accepted.
And these are you know, these are very important
books and also how we present our history.
Speaker 1: Last thing I want to ask you about.
What do you make of the tie between actual issues
of suppression of speech by governments and some
of the sort of cancel culture, social media,
private business discussion that now is going
on? Certainly legally. I think at this point,
most of us, although some people call me
and they don't seem to get this difference,
most of us understand that legally Twitter can
have terms of service wherein they don't allow
certain types of statements to be made. It's
not a First Amendment issue. It has nothing to
do with that that we understand. So we can
sort of skip beyond that. But ideologically
and from a principals standpoint,
when there is not a legal issue,
what would an organization like yours
say about some of the terms of service
on these social media platforms that
do limit the things that are allowed?
Speaker 5: But we understand the power of
social media and and we understand why the
decisions that get made on social media are
so are so important to people. We have we have
an arts advocacy project ourselves, you know,
trying to push back against algorithms that are
banning all nudity, for example, including
artistic nudity from from social media.
But ultimately, you know, we hold with the view
that that the companies have to be allowed as as
is their First Amendment right to make decisions
about what content they allow and don't allow.
And, you know, and and unfortunately, at this
point, you know, there are efforts underway.
There are laws that have recently been passed
in Texas and in Florida that are trying to force
social media companies to accept content that they
don't want. Right. And that, you know, that is a
step toward government, you know, government
intervention in free speech that we just can't
we can't allow that we have to challenge.
Speaker 1: Yeah, that's an important point.
It's ultimately government intervention
either way. And that's that's a critical
point we've been speaking with Chris
final. And who's the executive director
of the National Coalition Against Censorship?
The book is How Free Speech Saved Democracy,
which we will link to from our YouTube
clip for this interview. Chris,
really appreciate your time today.
Speaker 5: Thanks for having me.